the media continued to pump bad news
even if the news is actually kind of
good governor Rhonda census of Florida
finally goes ape on reporters at the
Michael Flynn case gets more and more
curious this is the Ben Shapiro show the
Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by express
at VPN you have a right to privacy
protect it at expressvpn comm slash Ben
so we actually have a lot of good news
the last couple weeks have been a time
of good news now listen there's never
unqualifiedly good news in the middle of
a pandemic there are always going to be
more deaths there is always going to be
more suffering that is just the reality
of life but if you had told people
several weeks ago that the curve would
be flattened that stage would be
beginning to reopen and he wouldn't see
these massive spikes as those states
reopen that in fact many of the states
reopening are seeing lower rates of
infection and death and they were even
when they were closed you would think
that was kind of a bit of good news
would you not what if he found out that
the virus is not as he's only
transmissible as it was once thought to
be meaning that if it's going to be
transmitted it is mainly done through
face-to-face contact as I mentioned
yesterday the CDC downgraded its risk
assessment level from getting this thing
on surfaces they basically said that's
pretty unlikely you're gonna get this
from services now at CNN there's a piece
suggesting that staying safe isn't just
about staying six feet away from others
and washing your hands with soap it's
about staying away from people in closed
areas for significant amounts of time
Aaron Bromwich a communitive a
comparative that new knowledge is and
professor of biology at University of
Massachusetts Dartmouth summed it up
with a short and sweet equation
successful infection equals exposure to
virus times time meaning that you
actually have to be exposed to the virus
for a long period of time which is why
you're seeing a lot of medical workers
who are getting this because they are in
contact with people who have this for
long periods of time
nursing home workers have gotten this
but if you just walk through a room or
somebody sneezed five minutes beforehand
the chances that you're gonna get this
are actually pretty low fromage is
simplified formula was part of a recent
blog post explaining ways to lower your
risk of catching kovat 19 the main idea
is people get infected when they are
exposed to a certain amount of viral
particles that viral threshold can be
reached by an infected person sneeze or
cough which releases a large number of
viral particles into the air but an
infected person talking or even just
breathing releases some virus into the
air over a long period of time in an
enclosed space that means that the viral
load in the area obviously
increases so this is why you've seen for
example widespread infections during
choir practices people are singing and
they're projecting and they're in very
close contact with one another but if
you have if you have restaurants where
people are seated fairly power far apart
or outside then you don't see a lot of
people who aren't infecting other people
and this also means that there may be
some good ways to alleviate this sort of
stuff namely make sure that the air
conditioning ventilation in particular
restaurants is better make sure that
you're sitting a little bit further
apart make sure that you don't spend an
hour at the restaurant spend 10 minutes
at the restaurant you know sitting down
outside for coffee or something the
bottom line is that that is good news it
means that you are probably not gonna
get this just from walking around this
is what you would suspect anyway because
we've had tons of people going to
grocery stores and virtually nobody is
getting it at the grocery store a few of
the grocery clerks have been getting it
because again they are experiencing lots
of people directly across from them and
that is why they put up the spit guards
which is a good thing but we've had
grocery stores that are basically chock
full of people you haven't seen viral
outbreaks at Walmart for example why
because you're just not in constant
contact to people for very long you're
brushing past them and you're moving on
you are saying into churches why because
you're sitting on a Pew next to somebody
else for like an hour you saw it at mini
Onam in the Jewish community spreading
very widely because again you are
sitting in a room that is closed for two
hours at a time and so that is let while
singing so that is likely to lead to
wider viral spread all of this is good
news and yet the media seem just
desperate desperate to continue
portraying all the news in the worst
possible light I'll show you a couple
examples of this in just a moment
because instead of just reporting the
facts as they come in and reporting them
with any level of complexity and nuance
which is the real world instead the
media basically looked for a headline
that says things are bad and then just
repeats that headline even when it
doesn't actually mesh it with the fact
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the reality which
is you probably don't want to be hanging
out inside an enclosed auto parts store
standing in line with people for hours
at a time right now only to get to the
front and realize they only have the
generic part that ain't gonna fit your
car all that well or they have to order
it online you could just order it online
from home instead of going to the auto
parts store and then having to be
charged the markup go to Rock Auto comm
rockauto.com they always offer the
lowest possible prices rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do well I spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
like so you need to happen hat you
happen to need a Delphi FG 1456 fuel
pump assembly
for 2005 to 2010 honda odyssey and it
costs like 354 bucks at a big chain
store that's the kind of thing you could
get at Rock Auto for 217 bucks
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com
i reliably low the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brands specifications and
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need head on over Rock
Auto calm right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
Shapiro's in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you check them out at Rock Auto calm so
as I say it seems like a lot of the
media are really intent on painting
worst case scenario as the probable
scenario even when the evidence doesn't
actually support that and so you'll see
a lot of headlines about modeling these
days but the headline from the modeling
is completely unrelated to reality so
for example Matt Drudge who over at
Drudge Report has really been playing up
sort of the disastrous side of the
pandemic and Matt's great at his job but
the reality is that if you watched her
Drudge Report you would be in a state of
sheer panic nearly all the time about
coronavirus and he's been taking this
thing to the next level now to be fair
it to man he also did this with Ebola
right anytime there's a viral outbreak
anywhere Matt covers it with extreme
extreme sort of telescopic view or
microscopic view rather I mean it was a
real spotlight on it but he headlined
today over at The Drudge Report this new
model that suggests that some 5 million
people could be infected and a quarter
million people could be dead by August
but he's a big headline today saying
some are scary models predicts quarter
million dead by August ok well there's
only one problem that model that he is
citing is a model from the University of
Pennsylvania's Wharton School they
predicted the kovat 19 cases could reach
5.4 million in the death toll could be
290 thousand if every state in America
were to fully reopen with no social
distancing and no mask-wearing has
anybody talked about this like at all
there's not a single state in America
where people aren't recommending social
distancing in mask-wearing and by and
large Americans like 80 percent of
Americans are very very cautious in
their approach to this thing seventy to
eighty percent of Americans are very
much in favor of mass pouring
particularly when you are enclosed
areas and I'm one of the people who's
been urging that caution when you're
outside you're far away from people and
you're not getting this thing when you
are inside wearing the mask is just
common courtesy honestly at this point
until we know more okay but this model
sighting the top line of the model is
nearly useless I mean that is like
saying that if there were no speed
limits in the United States and if
everybody just decided to drive 120
miles an hour you'd have five times as
many deaths and car accidents okay but
your premise is completely false there
are speed limits and nobody's driving
120 miles an hour because they wouldn't
even if they could they'd be afraid of
dying and so so there's this piece from
The Daily Mail which says the ominous
forecast from the University of
Pennsylvania's Wharton School model
accounts for all states fully reopening
with no social distancing measure in
comparison the model predicts nearly 4.3
million cases and 230,000 deaths by July
24th if states reopen but individuals
maintain their social distancing efforts
stays only partially reopened by lifting
stay at home owners but social
distancing measures are still adhered to
the mark at the for the model forecast
30.4 a 3.1 million infections and 172
thousand deaths the best case scenario
which would involve each state
maintaining lockdown restrictions as of
may 17th with social distancing and
measures still in place
there could be 2.8 million infections at
157 thousand deaths so you're talking
about the difference between two hundred
and ninety thousand deaths at 172
thousand deaths even according to this
model but by the way this particular
model also happens to be extraordinarily
pessimistic there's a separate model
from the University of Massachusetts
influenza forecasting sensor they
project that deaths could surpass one
hundred and thirteen thousand by
mid-june but let's be real about the
models the models are variable they
change really fast I mean we were
originally told that if there are no
social distancing measures that on the
upper end we'd be looking at 2.2 million
deaths in the United States that is the
Imperial College model so relying on
models rather than the data as they come
in seems to be not all that effective
also worth noting while we focus heavily
in the United States on lockdown policy
there is no good correlation between the
states that have locked down in the
states that have not locked down now
it's quite possible that in high
population density centers like like New
York City then a lockdown is absolutely
necessary but South Dakota didn't lock
down Vermont did lock down they have
kind of the same population and they
have basically the same number of deaths
this by the way holds true across
Europe there's a study from Bloomberg
today it says with governments across
Europe reopening their economies for
business it's a good movement it's a
good moment to look back on the
different paths taken to control Cova 19
outbreaks to try to see how effective
they were the chart below shows the
relative severity of Europe's
restrictions based on work done by the
University of Oxford's Bava tannic
School of Government which tracks a
range of measures and scores have
stringent they've been each step of the
way for many European countries
stringency levels increased
substantially after the w-h-o declared a
pandemic even when their caseloads were
low well not a gauge whether the
decisions taken were the right ones nor
has strictly they were followed the
analysis gives a clear sense of each
government strategy for containing the
virus some like Italy and Spain enforce
prolonged and strict lockdowns after
infections took off others like Sweden
preferred a more relaxed approach
Portugal and Greece chose to close down
laudable cases were relatively low
France and the UK took longer but there
is little correlation between the
severity of the nation's restrictions
and whether it managed to curb access
fatalities a measure that looks at the
overall number of deaths compared with
normal trends so among the countries
that have very high extremely high
excess mortality you're looking at
England being in that group Italy is in
that group on the low end of the group
is Berlin Sweden is sort of similar in
the middle of the pack in terms of
excess mortality so the UK Netherlands
in Spain had very very high excess
mortality Sweden and Switzerland they
had excess mortality but significantly
less than the first group and then there
was Greece and Germany so according that
Bloomberg study the overall impression
is that while restrictions on movement
were seen as a necessary tool to halt
the spread of the virus when and how
they were wielded was more important
than their severity early preparation
plentiful healthcare resources weren't
enough for several countries to avoid
draconian lock downs so in other words
the faster you got on it the less it
mattered whether you locked down if he
got on it really fast and you were able
to test really fast you didn't have to
lock down in the first place so it was
the timing and not actually the lockdown
measures that mattered which is why
Vermont which was not hard hit it
doesn't matter whether they lock down or
not because again they weren't hard hit
South Dakota which was not hard it
didn't matter whether they locked down
or not because they weren't hard it New
York it would have mattered an awful lot
if they had locked down a little bit
earlier in fact there was a study out
today suggesting that many many fewer
people would have died in New York if
they had actually locked down much
sooner and these modelers in the United
States again suggest that tens of
thousands of US deaths could have been
prevented if everybody locked down
a lot earlier but that was mostly in
places like New York they suggest that
if the town had happened early March
like a week earlier then it could have
prevented some 36,000 deaths my only
doubt about that is if these deaths were
taking place at nursing homes and if
people with coven 19 are being shoved
back into the nursing homes and 4050
percent of all deaths were happening in
nursing homes I'm not sure that that is
exactly the case but the media are
pushing this a little bit because the
idea is that if you precipitously remove
lock down then you're gonna have a
second wave spike that's going to swamp
the system again I think that the data
for that are very much up in the air I
do not think the data are very clear now
as I say the media are definitely
attempting to push a particular
narrative here I'll give you another
example in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that it is very
important these days to know exactly who
is at your door I've had two friends in
the last month who people tried to rob
them and thanks to ring.com they were
able to hand the tape over to the
authorities because they knew who is at
their front door because they could see
people actually fleeing from their home
ring calm it makes your neighborhood
safer it makes your home safer there's a
reason put those people put those ring
signs outside their home to let would-be
thieves know that they are now on tape
ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around the clock from video
doorbells and security cameras to smart
security lighting and alarm systems ring
has everything you need to make sure
your family and belongings are safe and
secure anytime anywhere with the all new
ring video doorbell three you can keep
an even closer eye on things than ever
before ring gives you protection at
every corner video tour bells let you
answer the door and check in on your
home anytime keep an eye on your
doorstep or speak to delivery people
when you can't come to the door without
door security cameras you can check in
on every part of your house and never
miss a moment smart lighting brightens
up blind spots make sure you always come
home to a brightly lit house full home
security systems give you everything you
need to protect your family pets and
property get a special offer on the rim
welcome kit when you go to ring com
slash been that welcome kit includes the
ring video doorbell three and try and
pro it's all you need to do start
building custom security for your home
today
just turn it over to ring calm at /bin
again that is ring comm / button we've
been using ring at our house for four
years because we are worried about
security you should be to check out ring
calm make your home more secure so in
another example of the media just
blatantly miss covering the news
blatantly miss covering it there's a
piece at the LA Times by Hanna Frey at
wrong homeland the second luke money and
Colleen Chou
so half the team it's called a new high
for coronavirus deaths in California as
counties push ahead with reopening so
what would you get from that headline
what you'll get from that headline is
this is risky guys we can't reopen while
there's a high-end estimator we crazy we
just had the daily high-end deaths and
here you are pushing for precipitous
reopening and then you read the article
and here's what you find they say
California recorded 132 new coronavirus
related fatalities Tuesday the most in a
single day since the pandemic began as
counties across the state continue
cementing plans to reopen their
economies first of all note California
has 40 million people living here 132
deaths every one of those the tragedy
every one of those is horrible
statistically speaking that is not a
massive number in the state of
California the highest number of deaths
previously reported in a single day
statewide was 117 in late April so this
was the highest day but that's because
California has not been particularly
hard hit by the corona virus in terms of
number of deaths but that's not even
what I'm talking about here what I'm
talking about is buried in paragraph 6
is well the death count continues to
rise other metrics shows significant
progress enough that even some of the
most cautious local health officials
have agreed to begin slowly reopening
businesses and public spaces the number
of newly identified coronavirus cases
across California decline from the
previous week hospitalizations have
dropped more than 15% from a peak six
weeks ago according to a Times analysis
so the peak happened six weeks ago right
there's a trailing number of deaths
because again there are a lot of people
in the hospital who linger before
unfortunately they pass away hospital is
hospitalizations have dropped more than
15% by the way I know a bunch of people
work in hospitals in this region in this
area they're empty the hospitals are
completely empty in people who are going
in and staffing the hospitals and
literally sitting there watching Netflix
all day because they do not have any
patients patients are not showing up to
the hospitals my wife had to go in for a
covered test maybe a week and a half ago
she was literally the only person in the
kovat room waiting for a test at UCLA
the only person and UCLA is a rather
major hospital in LA County which has
become the center of the corona virus
outbreak in California with more than
1,900 deaths in early 40,000 cases
officials have cautioned that reopening
the economy will be more difficult than
in other parts of the state but the
reality is that outside of LA County
there are not a lot of cases and again
the the peak has been reached in
California for weeks at this point and
yet the headline there is record number
of deaths
in California this sort of media
coverage is irresponsible the headline
does not match the actual content to the
piece the headline should be California
hits high in deaths but other indicators
show it's on the downswing might mean
that that would be the either to be
accurate headline not look at these
crazy people reopening as we've hit a
maximum number of deaths if that's a
lagging indicator it is not a good
indicator and then you see headlines
like this from the Washington Post
coronavirus hot spots erupt across the
country
experts warn of second wave in south
they say Dallas Houston Southeast
Florida's Gold Coast the entire state of
Alabama several other places in the
south that have been rapidly reopening
their economies are in danger of a
second wave of coronavirus infections
over the next four weeks according to a
research team that uses cell phone data
to track social mobility and forecast
the trajectory of the pandemic the model
developed by the policy lab at
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia
updated Wednesday with new data suggest
most communities in the United States
should be able to avoid a second wave
spike in the near term if are careful to
maintain social distancing even as
businesses open up and restrictions are
eased but the risk for resurgence is
high in some parts of the country
especially in places where cases are
already rising fast including the
counties of Crawford Iowa Colfax
Nebraska Texas Oklahoma and the city of
Richmond since May 3rd Crawford case the
county caseload has risen by seven
hundred and fifty percent
there are preliminary signs that hot
spots could flare across parts of the
South and Midwest why well because
they're saying that basically they're
tracking cell phone data and they are
seeing people moving more that is a
again that is a that is a model if you
want to point to the counties where
they're actually having hot spots why
don't you point to the counties where
they're actually having hot spots don't
point to the places where they don't
have hot spots yet
right room remember the article begins
by saying Dallas Houston Southwest
Florida's Gold Coast and Alabama and
then where are the actual counties
they're citing that have had a spike
Crawford Iowa Colfax in Nebraska Texas
Oklahoma and the city of Richmond which
last I checked we're not talis Houston
southeast Florida Gold Coast and the
entire state of Alabama now maybe there
is going to be a spike in those places
maybe that's going to happen but to
headline the headline again was
coronavirus hot spots erupted across the
country experts warned of second wave in
south that makes it sound like oh you
know like the most populous areas in
america are about to get just absolutely
savaged we've been hearing that about
Georgia for month
giorgia hit a low in number of diagnosed
cases yesterday we have a surplus of
testing capacity in most states and
people not taking advantage of the tests
this sort of reporting is just not
responsible it is not it is not
reflective of reality we're seeing the
same thing with regard to reporting on
children by the way and there's all this
reporting on how children are at risk we
can't reopen the schools Washington DC I
believe just announced they're not going
to reopen the schools in September which
is crazy it's May how do you how do you
announce the hell you're doing in
September I would not be shocked to see
LA County do exactly the same thing
saying we're not reopening the schools
by the way Taiwan never closed at
schools Denmark never closed its schools
because you know what they kind of
figured out early
kids are not passing this thing at least
not very easily by all available studies
there's yet to be a single study showing
that kids are passing this thing at the
same rate as adults there has yet to be
a single study showing there significant
risk to children in fact the fatality
rate from Kovan 19 among children is
about 1/3 that from the flu okay among
older people it's a lot more than the
flu among younger people like not
tranching the population when you look
at the overall case fatality rate or
infection fatality rate is really really
stupid and the reality is that a study
in the Journal of American Medical
Association Pediatrics last week found
that only forty eight children 48 total
between March 14th and April 3rd were
admitted to 14 pediatric ICUs in the
u.s. 83% had an underlying condition
that's 48 children total in like three
weeks in that same period tens of
thousands of Americans were dying the
fatality rate for kids in the ICU is
five percent compared to fifty to sixty
two percent for adults also kids don't
seem to be carrying this thing at the
same rate there been a bevy of studies
from a variety of sources ranging from
Australia to China showing the kids were
more likely to pick up the virus from
their parents and vice-versa and that
they're really not passing it to adults
Australia's National Center for
immunization research and surveillance
tracks Cova 19 cases at 15 schools from
March 1st April 16th at the outset 18
individuals were infected after six
weeks two of their 863 closed contacts
at the school had become infected so
kids are not passing this at school is
what we've been finding in a fair number
of these studies and as for the
reporting about this this sort of
kawasaki the
Kawasaki disease syndrome that has been
popping up that is among a vast vast
vast minority of kids so how was that
report it was reported as top-line news
in every major newspaper now again I
think that we should all be cautious
none of this I keep saying this over and
over because people deliberately in the
media will mystery to anything to
suggest that if you are skeptical a
full-scale lockdown is because you want
everybody to just ignore all the social
distancing and mask-wearing requirements
there are some people who are doing that
it is a small percentage of people the
vast majority of people are up for the
aamna wear a mask when I go out and when
I'm with honorable people most people
are up for that but the media coverage
here is just it really is astonishing
because again they will say that states
that have not yet been hit hard are
about to get hit hard meanwhile they
will just frankly cover up for governors
who have done an absolute garbage job
they take for example I mean they're
ripping governor's who have never fully
locked down and they're and they are
just praising governors who locked down
with did a garbage job take for example
the most trusted name in news over at
CNN first of all I don't know how it's
journalistically ethical to have Chris
Cuomo covering his brother he said I was
under the misimpression that if you are
actually related to the person you are
covering that generally is not good
journalistic practice wait until you
hear Chris Cuomo doing his doing his
buddy cop routine with his broheim last
night on CNN pretty pretty astonishing
stuff most trusted name of news we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about a simple fact two out
of three Jews are gonna experience some
form of male pattern baldness by the
time they are 35 the best way to prevent
hair loss do something about it well I
still have the hair you just have to go
to the doctor's office for your hair
loss prescription now thanks to keebz
you can visit a doctor online get hair
loss medications delivered right to your
home they make it easy deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
an awkward doctor visit prevention is
key keeps treatments can take up to four
to six months or more to see results
it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair you
will save find out why keeps has more
5-star reviews than any of its
competitors nearly 100,000 men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication keeps treatments start at
just ten bucks a month plus for a
limited time you can get your first
month for free now I've been taking
keeps myself and I am happy with it
because it is allowing me to get the the
drug that I need that will keep my hair
on my head
is kind of important in my particular
industry if you're required to take
action and prevent hair loss go to keeps
calm / bench receive your first month of
treatment for free that is ke e PS calm
/ Ben and keep that hair despite all the
stress go check out keeps calm so I
spend that is ke e PS calm / Ben alright
so let's talk about the media's
differential coverage of states who
talked about sort of broadly speaking
the media trying to play up bad news
everywhere that they possibly can
including basing it on the modeling as
opposed to you know basing it on the
actual outcome in places like Georgia
remember by the way when we were talking
about the dire outcomes for ventilators
how offensive leaders were necessary
more and more ventilators where
everybody's gonna die without events
later turns out that the vast majority
of people who are on ventilators died so
I mean that and that just disappeared
from the news meanwhile by the way
Georgia which is supposed to be you know
completely ripped up only 866
ventilators are in use in Georgia they
have a supply of nearly 3,000
ventilators but don't worry the media
are gonna rely on projections that have
been wrong in virtually every state here
and that's not to say that we should
disregard the projections it is to say
that the projections change based on new
data as it comes in we just don't know
very much about how this virus operates
I mean so meanwhile the media have been
covering States differentially I will
explain you know a perfect example
Florida Ron de santis ripped up and down
up and down we talked yesterday on the
program about how Ron de santis is one
of the few governors who actually took
the proactive step of saying we are not
shipping patients with Kovan 19 who are
in nursing homes back into nursing homes
but meanwhile he's being ripped for
keeping the beaches open well yesterday
Ron de santis went on his hair against
the media I mean honest I've been
waiting months for him to do this here
he was yesterday just blowing blowing
through the media it was pretty great
data is available our data is
transparent in fact after Burks has
talked multiple times about how Florida
has the absolute best data so any
insinuation otherwise is just typical
partisan narrative trying to be spun and
part of the reason is that because you
got a lot of people in your profession
who wax poetically for weeks and weeks
about our Florida was going to be just
like New York wait two weeks Florida is
going to be next
just like Italy wait
two weeks well hell were eight weeks
away from that and it hasn't happened
not only do we have a lower death rate
while we have way lower deaths generally
we have a lower death rate than the
Acela court or DC everyone up there we
have a lower rate death rate than the
Midwest Illinois Michigan Indiana Ohio
but even in our region Louisiana
Mississippi Alabama Georgia Florida has
the lower death rate and I was the
number one landing spot from tens of
thousands of people leaving the number
one hot zone in the world to come to my
state so we've succeeded and I think
that people just don't want to recognize
it because it challenges their narrative
it challenges their assumption so they
got to try to find a boogeyman maybe
it's that there are black helicopters
circling the Department of Health if you
believe that I got a bridge in Brooklyn
I'd like to sell you good for him
seriously good for him he's exactly
right on all this meanwhile you have
chris cuomo who's basically just giving
his brother a massage on national TV
every night last night
chris clark has chris cuomo ever asked
his brother about protecting nursing
homes of course not but you know what he
did - he did somebody comedy about how
his brother has a big nose and here's a
giant nasal swab for you this is the
normal swab I'm holding up here now and
for everybody at home a very valuable
object there's only one company in the
entire country that makes these up in
Maine all right here's this up is it
true that this was the swab that the
nurse was actually using on you and that
at first it went into your nose and
disappeared so that in scale this was
the actual swab that was being used to
fit up that double-barrel shotgun that
you have mounted on the front of your
pretty face so much news ink happening
over at CNN is great news in happening
over at CNN that guy is the worst
governor in America his state has
experienced 30,000 deaths 30,000 ie 15
times more deaths than Florida which has
a similar population that dude is a
terrible governor but his bro is on CNN
and by the way his bro who's breaking
quarantine and taking bleach baths in
order to fight his own coronaviruses is
your most trusted name inside
Tiffani's on Siena and then people
wonder why the right looks at CNN
cross-eyed because you guys are terrible
at your jobs I mean wow how is your
coverage bin of Phil Murphy in New
Jersey that's been widely praised across
the media look at him he's so he's so
strong on these lockdowns filmer if he'd
look how he's shutting down these gyms I
mean what what what a stud Phil Murphy
is it turns out that one in 13 people in
nursing homes in New Jersey is dead one
in 13 is dead that's Phil Murphy state
hey why because it turns out that the
state did virtually nothing to protect
people in nursing homes New Jersey calm
reports knowing nursing home residents
we're at grave risk state inspectors did
not begin to make on-site inspections
until April 16th according to officials
that was 36 days after New Jersey
reported its first death mat until
reports surfaced that one nursing
facility was storing 17 bodies in a
makeshift morgue asked why teams were
not since earlier state health
commissioner Judith per Shelly said in
mid-april they didn't have proper
fitting masks
she said she later gave hospitals first
dibs on PPE and she left a short supply
of ill-fitting masks for nursing home
inspectors so for weeks I just didn't
get any PPE which meant that some 89
people in nursing homes who worked there
died when nursing home operators
urgently called for staffing help they
received little assistance the National
Guard was not deployed until May the
state health department didn't announce
until earlier this month it would even
conduct widespread testing of nursing
home residents earlier this month May
this thing broke out in March the Health
Department refused to publish a list of
positive Kovan 19 cases until three
weeks after families pled with them to
tell them what the hell was going on
you've been seeing this in state after
state in Pennsylvania which has been
fairly hard hit the state health
director was taking his transgender
woman his own mother out of a nursing
home facility aged 95 well
simultaneously maintaining that nursing
home facility should take in people who
had kovat 19 have you heard any critique
of the governorship of Tom wolf in
Pennsylvania no you have not right only
around two Santa's only Brian Kemp the
differential media coverage is
astonishing it's astonishing so which is
it does the media love lockdown and
therefore are they praising governor's
who participate in lockdown
or is it media and the Democrats
basically have the same idea which is
they all have the same sort of political
biases if Democrats embrace a policy so
to the media because they are one in the
same I shouldn't be asking why the media
repeat democratic talking points the
real question is why I'm even separating
Democrats in the media because they
basically are the same thing at this
point mmm huge swathes of the so-called
objective media are just Democratic
aides at this point in time and by the
way you can also see this when you when
you talk about the coverage of the
Michael Flynn story so we have been told
that the Michael Flynn story is a
complete non story right - nothing
burger and in fact it's wrong to even
cover it you shouldn't cover the Michael
Flynn story you should only cover the
Michael Flynn story when Michael Flynn
was essentially being railroaded into
pleading guilty on the basis of not
committing a crime but you shouldn't
cover it when it turns out the DOJ
completely drops the case because it was
botched from beginning to end because
the investigation never should have been
maintained after early January and
because it turns out that high-ranking
members of the Obama administration were
involved in oversight of the Flynn
matter now we should just kind of let it
go why can't you guys just let this go I
mean it's been 27 minutes since the
story broke why can't you let the story
go the media wish to wish to ignore this
as long as possible you've had editorial
after editorial in major in American
newspapers saying well now why would we
cover this this is not worth covering
brian Stelter the watchdog at CNN why
are you covering this I don't know you
spent three years covering Trump brush'
allegations that turned out to be a bowl
of crap well why shouldn't we cover a
story in which it seems that members of
the Obama administration were pretty
intent on bending the rules even if they
were well-intentioned and thought that
there was Trump Russia collusion bending
the rules in order to get people
typically not good practice and if Trump
had done it about Obama incoming you
think that everybody would be quite so
sanguine of course not they're not even
saying what about the fact that the
Senate Intelligence Committee is now
looking into hunter Biden so why would
they be sanguine if Trump were going
after an Obama national security adviser
of Trump
we're basically unmasking Susan Rice
would they be super happy about that
especially if you're unmasking Susan
Rice in front of half the administration
and then a link to the press would that
be a genius move we'll get to this in
just one second because again the media
coverage here it just demonstrates
Democrats must have a ten-point
advantage in nearly every national
election simply based on the media
coverage that does not alleviate the
responsibility for Republicans to be
better at their jobs but it is simply
the case that Democrats have a massive
built-in advantage here we'll get to the
Michael Flynn case and the 2020 election
in just one second for
let's talk about the fact that the
double tumbler is back it's back it's
better than ever one to count them count
the tumblers two tumblers to do but it's
only available for our most exclusive
membership tier I'll access the
all-access memberships here is our
premier level of membership all access
members get to participate in all access
live our brand new interactive
programming featuring one of the daily
warehouses we hang out with you each
night all access members also get to
join us for real-time Q&A discussions
available on both the website and the
daily wire app so I believe I have the
all-access live tonight I have the helm
I have the I have the bridge and so
there will be as I always advertise
t-shirts and much singing of show tunes
in jar jar binks his voice and bizarre
impersonations and strange personal
questions answered to your liking I'll
access membership now includes two of
those irreplaceable leftist chairs
tumblers the tumblers are literally
overflowing with tears at the thought of
this offer people finally all excess
members get all the benefits of our
other membership tiers including an ADD
free website experience access to all of
our live broadcasts and show library
access to the shows mail bags and the
full three hours of the ben shapiro show
along with dedicated editorials from moi
so if you're not an all-access member
you are missing out head on over to
daily where calm slash subscribe join
all access get 15% off with coupon code
Shapiro right now
that's daily we're calm slash subscribed
we'll see you there you are listening to
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so looking at the media
coverage of the of the Flynn situation
oh yeah if you don't understand media
coverage just assume they're Democrats
and then it all makes sense so for
example there was a a memo that was
covered as a complete non story by Susan
Rice it was put out January twentieth
like the last day of the Obama
administration and the memo basically
said we should really you know we really
handled and should handle this whole
Michael Flynn thing by the book
it was a memo to file we have no idea
what the file was that's what you call a
cover-your-ass memo that is a memo that
is designed to say yeah we totally
listen we told everybody by the book the
only reason to write that is because you
don't actually feel that you did
something by the book now you're now
trying to cover up for the fact that you
didn't go by the book in the first place
Andrew McCarthy over at National Review
has a good piece on this he says rice
Susan Rice has gone from claiming to
have had no knowledge of Obama
administration monitoring of Flynn and
other Trump associates to claiming no
knowledge of any unmasking of Trump
associates to admitting she was
complicit in the unmasking 'he's too now
a call for a recorded conversation
between retired General Michael Flynn
and the Russian ambassador Sergei Kiss
lyac she wants that released because it
would purportedly show the Obama
administration had good reason to be
concerned about Flint by the way if
that's the case that doesn't really
explain why the why the people who are
on Mike Flynn side also are kind of in
favor of seeing this released
apparently Flynn's own lawyers are
interested in seeing the call released
simply so they can demonstrate that
there is nothing there that would have
justified the sort of wiretapping
that went on afterward Andrew McCarthy
says we have now learned that rice was
deeply involved in the Obama
administration's from Prussia
investigation including its sub
investigation of Lynne and also Rice's
previously unreported email
memorializing a White House meeting on
these subjects from January 20th is kind
of telling again why would you write a
memo to files saying we went right by
the book unless it were absolutely
necessary maybe it's to comment on a
meeting that took place January 5th and
involved rice Obama Biden the
administration's top political hierarchy
and national security matters along with
Obama's top law enforcement and
counterintelligence officials Deputy
Attorney General Sally Yates and FBI
director James Comey prior exactions
already demonstrated the meetings
central purpose was to discuss the
rationale for withholding intelligence
about Russia
from the incoming Trump national
security team Comey would join other
intelligence chief and chiefs and
briefing Trump on Russia's interference
in the 2016 campaign but they did
conceal the Obama administration's
investigation of the Trump campaign the
Obama administration hoped to conceal
what had done to the FBI in Justice
Department which comeon Yates would be
staying on to lead could continue the
investigation even after Trump took
office and they did just that the bureau
and goj renewed the FISA surveillance
warrants on Carter page which again were
deeply flawed and based on the crap
steal dossier there annuit twice more
clearly rice obama and biden realized he
would eventually become known to trump
and top advisers that the obama
administration had investigated his
campaign and had laid the groundwork to
persist in investigating his
administration the paten points of
Rice's last-second email written to the
file as she was leaving her office on
January 20th memorializing a meeting
that occurred two weeks earlier was to
shift responsibility from Obama to Comey
for the pursuit of the Trump Russia
probe right it says Obama says that we
should do this thing by the book and
James commis gonna do what James Comey
is going to do
that's essentially what the letter was
supposed to do the newly unredacted
paragraph from Rice's email relates that
Comey reported to Obama Biden and rice
on the FBI's investigation of Lynn the
FBI director is said to a framed it as
both a law enforcement matter the theory
that Flynn committed a crime by
violating the Logan act which was
nonsense and a national security matter
the suggestion that the bureau had had
some sort of damning information on
Flynn that should prevent him from being
part of the apparatus
according to rice Comey was
non-committal when asked whether Russia
intelligence should be withheld from
Flynn Rice claims Obama left the matter
of concealing information from the Trump
team unresolved now again this was
written this memo was written two weeks
after the original Trump meeting so all
of this is deeply suspicious and curious
but the media suggests that none of it
is worth covering it just isn't worth
covering and the reason it isn't worth
covering is because obviously if we were
to cover it and that would be suggesting
that the Obama administration was not
pure as the driven snow and was indeed
driven by ulterior motives even if they
thought those motives were good like
Trump is in bed with the Russians it
turns out that bending the law in order
to get there and then railroading
someone into a into essentially a
confession of a crime he didn't commit
he's a bad thing but we're not supposed
to cover all that according to the media
what we are supposed to cover is
President Trump firing
inspectors general so there have been a
couple inspectors general who have been
fired
credits who producer Nick for correcting
me on Inspector General's inspectors in
general so president Trump has fired a
couple of inspectors general he
specifically fired one over the State
Department and the idea was that Mike
Pompeo had this guy fired because he was
so close to the truth so close to the
truth Pompeyo yesterday came out and he
was like yes I had him fired yes there's
plenty of good reason I had him fired no
it wasn't because he was investigating
me this didn't stop chuck schumer from
bloviating on about it obviously without
all the information that's the way this
works
and so here's Chuck Schumer yesterday
saying it's dictatorship dictatorship
the Inspector General should have been
allowed to pursue this these cases on
his own without interference from either
the Secretary of State and certainly
without being fired by the president
it's outrageous it's outrageous and he's
done this time and time again the head
of Barda the head of Barda said
hydroxychloroquine is bad for you
Trump didn't like to hear that he fired
the guy it's like a dictatorship it's
not like a democracy we depend on truth
in this democracy and this president
runs away from it and it's hurting the
American people every day
I'm sorry such patent nonsense that that
story about ric reitz the guy was on the
chopping block for a year and he had
sent memos to people saying that he was
glad that they were expediting the
hydroxychloroquine clearance for doctors
so what we've seen in the last month a
bevy of stories about Trump randomly
firing people and how it has to be
nefarious and it has to be really bad
but if you ever mentioned by the way
that the Obama administration actually
fired people under some pretty curious
circumstances we shouldn't talk about
that very bad that the State Department
IG got fired very non worthy of coverage
that back during the Obama
administration the Inspector General
Gerald Walton was fired for trying to
protect taxpayer dollars basically
because Walton was going after the mayor
of Sacramento guy named Kevin Johnson
who happened to be an extraordinarily
close political ally of Barack Obama I
talk about this in my book the People vs
Barack Obama but it wasn't you know it
wasn't covered as a major scandal for
Obama
anytime Trump does something it's
covered as a major scandal for this
reason among others President Trump is
now trailing Joe Biden by significant
points now listen I'm not gonna put that
all on me
the media coverage of Trump has been
consistently bad obviously it was
consistently bad a bush also it was
consistently bad of Romney it doesn't
alleviate Trump's responsibility not to
get involved in stupid poop fights with
various Democrats but the media
certainly pay a major role here there's
a massive gap in the polls between
Americans right now so right now there's
an 11-point Biden lead 50 to 39 on the
president's handling of the economy 50%
of people still approve 47% of people
disapprove that is a slight decrease for
Trump compared to a 5144 gap in April on
health care the president is underwater
by about 13 points on Trump vs. Biden
Biden outscores Trump on honesty 47 to
41 people think that Trump is not honest
62 to 34
they say the biden has good leadership
skills 51 to 40% they say Trump is not
50 to 40% they said the Biden cares
about average Americans 61 230 Trump
does not 56 242 he's not supremely
favorable Biden he's got like a 45
percent approval rating Trump has about
a 40 percent approval rating by 16 point
margin 55 to 39 voters think that Biden
would do a better job than Trump
handling the response to the coronavirus
and and that would be the that would be
the big one right now that's that's the
thing that is really changing fairly
significantly his people's reactions to
trump and coronavirus and again a lot of
that is driven by the media and some of
that is driven by the fact that Trump
keeps getting caught in his own
silliness when he talks about this sort
of stuff but the reality is that if the
media covered any of this stuff and
even-handed fashion the gap would be
smaller not because they would be
portraying Trump anymore credibly but
because they would be pointing out that
the Democrats are absolutely awful at
this for example Joe Biden who is now
you know right now if the election were
held today who probably would Joe Biden
literally cannot get through six
sentences without stumbling it's
incredible but I didn't literally forgot
what he was talking about Lawton last
night and another virtual roundtable
there's a lot we can do that related to
what has already been passed with small
businesses that the president just just
hasn't hasn't done look you know
[Music]
a combination of failing and moved
quickly he's not there guys he's not
there if you talk about he's not there
then apparently you're ageist or
something but he is he's not all there
meanwhile Nancy Pelosi armature leader
Jennifer Rubin says she's a godsend to
the country because Jennifer Reubens a
good conservative columnist at the
Washington Post ah ha ha ha Nancy Pelosi
has now been relegated is it that as our
politicians get older their insults get
more childish here's Nancy Pelosi saying
that Trump is like a child with doggy
Doo on his shoes doggy Doo what what are
we in second grade here there's Nancy
Pelosi you're asking me about the
appropriateness of the actions of this
President of the United States so
completely inappropriate in so many ways
that it's almost a given it's like a
child who comes in with mud on their
pants or something that's the way it is
there after I playing that's with it he
comes in with doggy Doo on his shoes and
everybody who works with him has that on
their shoes too for a very long time to
come
doggy Doo on his shoes we've been
reduced to morbidly obese now you're
crazy yep yep doggy - I know she's what
in the we're like five seconds from I'm
rubber and you're glue right then we are
five seconds from that in this country
so this is honestly this is the best
case for Trump the best case for Trump
is everybody's incompetent you want them
all out of your lives that is the best
case for Trump and never has that been
better accentuated than by the fact that
Kamala Harris who may be the frontrunner
to get the VP nomination from Joe Biden
for no reason at all
she won nine votes not like series
hitting no votes in any of the primaries
for some reason people think that she
would strengthen Joe Biden's ticket
which makes no sense at all doesn't
bring anybody home to Joe Biden Joe
Biden blew her out with black voters
nobody likes camo Harris yet she's
perceived as some sort of some sort of
important voice to be added to the
ticket what's she been doing for the
past couple of weeks she has filed for a
resolution condemning all forms of
anti-asian sentiment related to Kovan 19
including the use of the terms Chinese
virus or Wu Han virus or Kong flu she's
introduced Senate resolution 580 which
is co-sponsored by Elizabeth Warren and
mazie Hirono of Y who has take
and Barbara boxer's slot is dumbest us
senator they say the public official
should denounce such rhetoric in any
form it also calls on law enforcement
officials to investigate document
prosecute the perpetrators of hate
crimes against Asian Americans by the
way not tons of data suggesting a
radical increase in hate crimes against
Asian Americans obviously we talk about
people being idiots and targeting Asian
Americans even Trump has repeatedly
condemned that but like are you kidding
me
that Kamala Harris is concerned right
now about calling it the the Chinese flu
like this is where we are our
politicians are our joke like nearly all
of them nearly all of them there very
few competent politicians that is the
best case for Trump not that he's
supremely confident but that everybody
else is similarly incompetent at least
he doesn't want to control your life
from paint the authoritarian here Nancy
Pelosi construction where are the
authoritarians here I've been saying for
a long time the pandemic is one of the
times when I'm most grateful that Trump
is president because of a Democrat were
president can you imagine the kinds of
federal control that would be attempting
to leverage over every aspect of
American life right now instead of try
and get the economy reopen they would be
talking about these sort of
transformational change that Joe Biden
has gotten very familiar with talking
about so the media will do their best to
obscure that but that that's what the
election really should be about what the
election should be about is who wants to
control your life more in the aftermath
of the greatest single crackdown on
American freedom in certainly my
lifetime certainly my parents's lifetime
who do you who do you want in there
somebody who wants more control or
somebody wants less control okay time
for some things that I hate
all righty so we obviously have a
serious problem of supply and demand in
this country when it comes to racism now
there are racists out there there are
people who are racist and do racist
things and those people should be
condemned that racist behavior should be
condemned we should all be unified in
condemning that behavior but what we see
in in the way that the media covered
things in the way that people respond to
things online is that every small
possibility of racism anything that can
be read as racism is read to the
broadest possible extent and then
imputed to American society as a whole
this is so there just is not enough of
the supply of racism in America to meet
the demand there's a high demand for
racism because people want to declare
that America is deeply brutal racist
homophobic hierarchical vicious they
want to claim all those things because
that allows them to argue for the
tearing down of the system right this is
where I talk about my new book how to
destroy America in three easy steps
it's coming out in July that they
require examples of American viciousness
in order to justify tearing down the
system from the inside in order to
justify eviscerating the system right
that that is the that's the goal so what
that means is that people will cease
specifically on controversial examples
of maybe racism maybe not in order so
that when somebody says wait I don't
actually see the evidence here they go
ah because you're a racist - right this
is why you will see the media did not
cover the Walter Scott shooting in South
Carolina in the same way that they are
covering the are berry shooting in
Georgia not at all why well the Walter
Scott shooting was pretty clearly racist
right I mean the the cop in that case
shot the guy in the back planted a gun
on the guy in everyone right that seems
pretty awful that guy should go to jail
and then he wants to jail for 20 years
and everybody was like alright good the
are berry shooting there's not tons of
evidence of racism inherent in the in
the case yet maybe it will materialize
but it seems like right now most of the
case is is a vigilante based all right
people who are told that a crime was
going on and decide we're gonna get our
guns we're gonna stop this guy and then
they went out there and it ended in in a
in a bad shooting and they will probably
end up going to jail for at the very
least manslaughter but if you say I'm
not seeing all the evidence of racism
yet then the implication is you don't
see the evidence of racism because
you're blind to racism generally okay
perfect example of this today perfect
example last night on Twitter I noticed
that the hashtag boycott FedEx was
coming up
I thought to myself boycott FedEx FedEx
is keeping the country running in the
middle of a pandemic the hell are you
talking about
why would I boycott FedEx okay so
there's a video that was going around by
a person in the Antonio Braswell and I'm
gonna play you the entire video it's
about 45 seconds long and what the video
shows is this fellow I think this is an
Tonio Braswell or he's the guy in the
truck unclear to me who which one he is
and it's a it's a vo guy in a FedEx
outfit who is yelling at and and being
filmed by what appears to be a white
homeowner Braswell was black and this
became the basis for the number one
hashtag on planet Earth last night
boycott FedEx here I'll play the tape
that I'll explain the account and then
I'll show you how in the absence of any
actual evidence people immediately left
to the conclusion that FedEx is a brutal
racist company here's the actual tape
last night I watched it three times make
sure I wasn't missing anything but you
don't have to come out there cutting me
like that like I'm some child ain't no
little boy oh no no well I went to the
police
[Music]
you can record are you all right girl ah
right there that's your power
that's this power that's why your power
we're right there gonna waste my time
with you you got my information you've
got my information me me you need to get
your glasses back on okay so then they
take off in the car so and is there
anything that um is there any evidence
that the white guy was being racist
there I mean really I don't see any
evidence I see that the person who is
driving the car is angry and I see a
confrontation but I have no idea what
led up to the confrontation literally no
idea you can't tell from the from the
tape itself there's nothing the white
guy isn't shouting slurs at the black
guy right in fact he barely says
anything he's I thought you were pretty
much the only thing he says I thought
you're gonna wait for the cops that's
pretty much the only thing he says in
the entire video okay so this fellow
tweets out the back story says he says
update Fed Ex called and told me to take
down this video and fired both of us
today I'm reposting this video because
people like him doesn't matter white or
any race you never disrespect essential
workers putting their lives in jeopardy
especially with this Cove in nineteen
now again I'm not seeing tremendous
disrespect in that video per se it looks
like two people who are kind of having a
fight and one is filming it in fact two
people were filming it right because the
the his this FedEx drivers friend inside
the truck was also filming it so then he
tells his backstories his backstory all
we did just deliver his package mind you
he was in the house it was a quick stop
as soon as we were leaving he ran out
his house cursing and threatening us and
we just apologized but he kept
escalating the situation then kept
saying he would whoop our black asses
now if that's caught on tape that's a
racist incident right then everybody's
unified because if somebody runs out of
the house after a FedEx guy drops off a
package and says he's gonna whoop your
black ass then pretty sure that's racist
and pretty sure that guy is in a hell of
a lot of media trouble right then that
that's the rent and should be and should
be ok but that part's not the part
that's on tape so this person says
that's when we told his wife to get the
police on us
he told that's when he kept following us
he pulled out his phone to record us and
start playing the victim role we drove
off at first but they yelled f ya'll so
we stopped the truck and that's when I
started recording the incident after the
video the police came and we told our
side of the story and the man said the
police they look like they would have
broke into my house while my wife is
there the white dude was lie
the whole time mind you all we all go
through this all the time he was
actually the first to come at us crazy
and all we doing is our job we work six
days out the week to deliver these
packages during this coronavirus going
on I really appreciate the job
opportunity I had with FedEx no hard
feelings I prayed and get back on my
feet because I have a daughter now
shoutout to my trainer he a real good
dude he taught me a lot 100% okay so I
don't know whether this guy's story is
true you don't have any idea whether
this guy's story is true presumably
there is more to the tape
presumably there is a police report
presumably there were several witnesses
to this exchange Twitter didn't care
Turner and Carol this friended number
one on Twitter boycott FedEx why because
FedEx fired these guys now maybe FedEx
did an investigation you never knew
about maybe FedEx called up the police
maybe FedEx called up the homeowner
maybe FedEx thought you know it's
actually not great policy having our
FedEx guys driving around taping the
customers right even if the customers
are taping us we just have a general
policy we don't want our employees tape
taping and publicly posting videos of
customers that's not an unreasonable
policy for FedEx to take it isn't okay
so this didn't matter
the idea was boycott FedEx because FedEx
was to blame now again we don't know
anything about this story other than the
guys account which we have no
verification of and the tape doesn't
show anything up doesn't matter this was
the number one trend in America again
the supply of racism is outstripped by
the demand in dramatic fashion people
had a virtue signal to demonstrate that
they took the story at face value
because if you don't take the story at
face value means you're a racist is the
way this works now online the way that
this works is an accusation is
tantamount to guilt no matter what so
long as the person who is making the
accusation is part of the the hierarchy
of groups who have been oppressed in
America before another example of this
so there's a piece at NBC News I'm not
kidding you it's called having a peloton
during the pandemic saved me but the
more I ride the more weary I get why so
what is wrong with peloton according to
the columnist David Kaufman he says the
company wants to be hashtag woke but if
I hear one more all white 1980s playlist
while a white coach uses black
vernacular to encourage riders all
scream so peloton is racist because
people are using 80s music which
very often is wise like Huey Lewis in
the news and sometimes uses black
vernacular when they talk here's what
this columnist says like many people in
quarantine everyday I find some time to
hide from my children and hop onto my
peloton I love my peloton which despite
the hefty price tag has much more than
paid for itself in burn calories and
much-needed Sun I'm clearly not alone
but the more I use my peloton bicycle
the more I don't feel so good about the
company behind it because just as there
are now infamous holiday season ad last
year convinced many people the company
had an unacknowledged gender problem
this is the dumbass controversy over an
ad in which a husband gives his wife a
Palatine bike and then she's real happy
about it which is bad you're never
supposed to give your wife an exercise
piece of equipment that she's unhappy
that she's happy about because it means
that your body shaming her gentlemen Hey
now this comment says their video and
music programming suggests to me as an
African American they also have an
unrecognized race problem it's not that
peloton the company is actively racist
or has even failed at being woke a quick
spin through peloton to a poor blog
reveals the brand is intentionally
including racially conscious content
throughout their marketing materials the
problem is more subtle subtle is code
for it doesn't exist but I'm just going
to make a big deal out of it so that I
can get some press with each bike priced
at over $2,200 plus $39 month per month
more for swimming classes peloton users
are typically Demi one-percenters with
cash to spare and home spacious enough
to house those speedy racers and in fact
peloton CEO and co-founder John Foley
said those users were his target
demographic those users must now find
free hours to actually ride their bikes
and run on their treadmills in between
other lockdown demands whether work
conferences or zoom classes for the kids
the upper middle class whiteness informs
everything I've experienced about
peloton almost cultish community of so
much whiteness so much whiteness that
community mostly connects during peloton
rides or runs which are streamed into
folks as homes on screens mounted on the
front of their equipment they love cutie
names the indicate effort level and
music genre think 30 minute pop ride or
45 minute hit and Hills ride upon
playing off the acronym for
high-intensity interval training and the
fact that you'll be hearing whatever is
atop the Billboard charts at the moment
this is where the race issue becomes
most apparent because black instructors
offer rides filled with typically black
music rap Caribbean or hip-hop while
white instructors offer ones with mostly
white music rock pop and heavy metal
though the thought that white people
don't workout to rap or hip-hop music
and black people don't use rock or pop
music to fuel their sessions in 2020
is laughable hold on so now you're
accusing a white trainer you don't know
of being a racist for not playing rap
music first of all I would guarantee you
that a huge percentage of the pot means
that they are playing is from people who
are of color right they're playing
probably Nicki Minaj they're probably
playing ariana grande a huge number of
those artists are people who are black
or Hispanic
but apparently very bit Rihanna right
this is very bad very bad he says the
deliberateness of those choices be
payments becomes more apparent in the
playlists of the rides with musical
themes from a specific decade whether
the 70s 80s or 90s also taught by mostly
white instructors such rides feature
popular era hit but for from
predominantly white bands so the 70s
focused rides are all classic rock and
bit of country the eighties rise are
full of new wave and the 90s classes are
big on grunge and Dave Matthews
it's as if black music let alone disco
or Tejano simply didn't happen during
those years and when black music does
appear outside of hip-hop or rap it's
often part of a more specialized class
categories such as groove ride are you
are you kidding me are you seriously
kidding me so peloton is racist now
because people choose the playlist that
they wish to play in order to draw a
crowd that they think will show up again
all this says is that America's a pretty
damn great place when you have to search
this hard for racism in peloton and a
final final example of this today so
wanna tell ray who I'm not Alana Delroy
fan i listen to pop music very much so I
don't really care I don't have a dog in
this fight
Lana Del Rey is now being dragged on
Twitter why because she put out a letter
today pointing out that she's been
criticized for not being feminist enough
in her music and then she says why is it
that everybody else gets to do their
version of feminism which could include
cheating or stripping or or being
terrible but my version of my version of
feminism which involves me exposing my
own vulnerabilities in my music is
considered very bad and so she has this
letter she says now that Doha Kat Ariana
Camilla cardi B Kalani and Nicki Minaj
and Beyonce have had number ones that
songs about being sexy wearing no
clothes
effing cheating etc can I please go back
to singing about being embodied feeling
beautiful by being in love even if the
relationship is not perfect or dancing
for money or whatever I want without
being crucified or saying that I'm
glamorizing abuse I'm fed up with female
writers and alt singers saying I
glamorize
abuse when in reality I'm just a
glamorous person singing about the
realities of what we are all now seeing
are very prevalent emotionally abusive
relationships all over the world with
all the topics women are finally allowed
to explore I just want to say over the
last 10 years I think it's pathetic
then my minor lyrical exploration
detailing my sometimes submissive or
passive roles in my relationships has
often made people say and set women back
hundreds of years let's be clear I'm not
a feminist but there has to be a kind of
place in feminism for women who look and
act like me and she talks about you know
some of the music that she has written
and she was ripped up and down for this
because she mentioned women of color
Lana Del Rey's a racist now she's a
racist for pointing out that there's
differential treatment between versions
of feminism and what women are allowed
to say now she's a racist again this all
comes down to people are looking for a
rationale for being racist people aren't
people are looking for a rationale for
suggesting that racism is rife in
American society so that they can claim
that the society itself is to blame for
the racism okay time for a very very
quick thing I like there's a great book
that I referred to on my all-access live
a couple of days ago called crisis of
the house divided by Harry Jaffa when we
talk about divisions in America it is
important to remember this is not the
most divided time in American history
there was a time when half the country
actually held slaves the the greatest
evil in American history by a long shot
Harry Jaffa has a great book about the
debates between Lincoln and Douglas and
the reading of the Declaration of
Independence into the Constitution the
second American founding that happened
during the Civil War the second American
founders would include people like
frederick douglass and include people
like Abraham Lincoln obviously it's a
great book it is not particularly an
easy read but Harry Jaffa is one of the
great American thinkers about American
philosophy and particularly the Civil
War here's a couple of fantastic books
on this crisis of the house divided is
an absolute classic you should go pick
it up today it'll teach you a lot about
American history and a ton about
American philosophy go check that out
right now okay I will be here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise I'll see you
her tomorrow or go subscribe right now
at dailyrx.com slash subscribe join our
all-access live later today where you'll
hear me do stupid people tricks also
join us on Wednesday at the 27th for a
backstage 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
so join say all sorts of goodies for you
when you become an all-access subscriber
go check it out right now I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by mic Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 the case for coronavirus
hysteria collapses even further as the
CDC changes its guidelines and admits
the virus does not spread easily if at
all through contaminated surfaces in
other words the masks and gloves are
basically useless Republican governor
Ron de santis takes a victory lap the
alarmist mayor of Atlanta makes excuses
and MSNBC's Mika Scarborough has an
on-air meltdown then leaked audio
services of Joe Biden discussing with
former ukraine president Petro
poroshenko the decision to fire that
prosecutor looking into Joe's son in
exchange for a billion dollar loan
guarantee that's just the beginning of
Joe's troubles finally the mailbag check
it out on the Michael Noel's show
you
[Music]